يقال مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي جيك
سولفان ان الرئيس الامريكيه جو بايدن اعطى
ضوء اخضر ليشركاء الاوروبيين لبدء برنامج
تدريب الطيارين الاوكرانيين على طائرات اف
16 الامريكيه واكد سولفا في حديثا لشبكه
سي ان ان الامريكيه ان بلاده ستقدم الدعم
اللازم لتسهيل وتسريع عمليه التدريب
اعطى الرئيس الضوء الاخضر للشركاء
الاوروبيين وسنسمح وندعم ونوفر لهم
المعدات اللازمه لبدء تدريب الاوكرانيين
على طائرات اف 16 بمجرد ان يجهز
الاوروبيون الذين قالوا انهم يحتاجون الى
اسبوعين ليتمكنوا من انشاء مرافق التدريب
اللازمه وقد اكد الرئيس اننا سنلبي اي
جدول زمني يحتاجه شركاؤنا الاوروبيون
اليوم او غدا او بعد غد لا يهم لن تقف
الولايات المتحده حجر عثره في طريق ضمان
بدء برنامج التدريب هذا
واضاف سالبا ان ذخائر العنقوديه الامريكيه
وصلت الى اوكرانيا وذكر في حديثا لشبكه سي
ان ان الامريكيه ان تقديم هذه الذخائر جاء
تعويضا لنقص قذائف 155 ملم التي يتطلب
انتاجها بعض الوقت
القذائف العنقوديه وصلت الى اوكرانيا ليس
لدي معلومات عما اذا كانت قد نشرت بالفعل
على جبهات لكن اذا لم يحصل ذلك بعد فستكون
هناك خلال الساعات او الايام القادمه
لانها شحنت بسرعه كبيره لتكون في ايدي
الاوكرانيين على الخطوط الاماميه توفير
الذخائر العنقوديه للاوكرانيين جاء لسد
الفجوه بين الحاجه اليها اليوم ونقص
الذخيره من عيار 155
التي يحتاج تصنيعها وتعويضها بضعه اشهر
وقد صمم الرئيس بايدن على عدم ترك
اوكرانيا دون حمايه
بدوره قال منسق والاتصالات الاستراتيجيه
في مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي جون كاربي
قال ان هناك اتصالات وثيقه مع شركات
الانتاج الدفاعي لزياده انتاج القذائف
الذي انخفضت مخزوناتها واضف كاربي في
مقابله مع شبكه فوكس نيوز انه تم تزويد
اوكرانيا بالقذائف العنقوديه لتعويض النقص
الحاصل
مع الصناعات الدفاعيه لزياده انتاجها خاصه
من القضاء في المدفعيه وقد رايتم كيف
قدمنا بعض الضخائر العنقوديه لاوكرانيا
كحل مؤقت لحين تكفيف الانتاج ونعتقد اننا
سنكون قادرين على الوصول لاهدافنا في
تعويض المخزون
الينا لان من واشنطن المراسله الجزيره
بسان ابو كويك اذن الضوء الاخضر اعطي من
قبل الولايات المتحده للشركاء الاوروبيين
لتدريب الطيارين على طائرات
سته عشر بيسان وكذلك القنابل العنقوديه
الامريكيه تم تاكيد ارسالها الى اوكرانيا
ماذا بعد في هذه التصريحات
ايمان يعني جايك كان ربما يرد على تساؤلات
وتقارير كانت قد وردت بان الاوروبيين
يقولون بان التصديق او المصادقه النهائيه
على تدريب الاوكرانيين على استخدام طائرات
الابسه عشر كانت معطله هنا في واشنطن من
قبل وزاره الخارجيه المعنيه بذلك الامر
وطبعا لوزاره الدفاع دور كبير في ذلك جيك
سالب يقول ان الرئيس بايدن اعطى الضوء
الاخضر لتلك التدريبات ولكن الاوروبيين
مازالوا بحاجه لعده اسابيع كي يجهزوا
المرافق والمنشات الخاصه بتلك التدريبات
وان الولايات المتحده على استعداد كامل
لتوفير الدعم وتسهيل اتاحه تلك التدريبات
وان ذلك
ان كان اليوم او غدا او بعد غد هذه ليست
القضيه الخلافيه الامر
محسوم ولكن بانتظار جهوزيه الجانب
الاوروبي لبدء تلك التدريبات وكان هناك
تقارير بان تلك التدريبات ستبدا الشهر
المقبل كان هناك ايضا تلك التقارير التي
نقلتها صحيفه بوليتيكو عن ذلك التاخير بان
وزاره الخارجيه ما زالت بصدد اصدار
التصديق النهائي خصوصا وان على الجانب
الامريكي توفير تعليمات حول كيفيه
تسيير تلك التدريبات وذلك يتطلب بعض
المعلومات التي التي تعد سريه كيفيه اداره
تلك الطائرات
للمضيق في تلك التدريبات ايضا تحدث عن
عضويه اوكرانيا في حلف
النيتو وخصوصا بعض القمه التي شارك بها
الرئيس بايدن امس قال ان ذلك امر محسوم في
مستقبل اوكرانيا ولكن الان تحديدا نظرا
لان اوكرانيا في حاله حرب في حال تم
انضمامها الى حلف الناتو فذلك يعني ان
الحلف والولايات المتحده ستكون في حرب مع
روسيا وانا هناك ايضا امور متعلقه
بالاصلاحات داخليا اصلاحات ديمقراطيه داخل
اوكرانيا يجب ان تتم بعضها تم وان ذلك
الامر سيحتاج بعض الوقت وانا التفاوض سيتم
بشكل مباشر حين او يحين الاوان لذلك بسبب
كويك مراسله الجزيره شكرا لك من واشنطن